>>Ariana: Hi.
My name is Ariana.
I'm in 8th grade, and I'm writing a book
about a corrupt government
that went too far.
>>Wally: I'm Wally, and I'm
writing a book about a kid
with supernatural abilities.
>>Girl: I'm writing a novel
about a girl getting sucked
into an alternate universe.
>>Girl: My book is about
trying to escape an island.
>>Boy: People trying to figure out what
happened to their very healthy yet,
for some reason, dying father.
>>Caitlyn: I'm Caitlyn, and I wrote
my first novel, "Neglected Heroes,"
when I was in the 8th grade.
>>Wally: When I think of a novel, I
think about a pretty, a pretty fat book.
And writing that much
seems pretty impossible.
>>Ariana: Especially when my teacher
first said it, she was just like,
"You're going to write a book."
And I was like, what?
>>Boy: I also felt super-freaked-out,
because I had no idea
what I was going to do.
>>Caitlyn: I was convinced
that it was only something
that adults were allowed to do.
>>Girl: The biggest challenge
was setting up all the characters
and then getting the setting.
>>Girl: And to take that feedback
and to turn it into something better.
>>Ariana: I think the most exciting part
about writing this novel in 30 days is
that I never thought I'd do it.
>>Boy: It is possible to write
a book in just one month.
>>Caitlyn: When I published
my novel, I felt invincible.
>>Ariana: Well, now impossible
just seems so much more reachable.
>>Girl: Don't give up.
>>Wally: Everyone has a story.
>>Ariana: Well, the ending
of my story is going
to be the main character's friends die.
Yeah.
>>Wally: And then they're
going to defeat the bad guy.
The End.